on vous entend oui donc qui vous faut-il
attendre de ce sommet on y arrive en
pratique dans la mesure où si cet accord
était prévu en grande pompe à l'abc les
bourses réunion avec tous les européens
et liège moi le fait tous un peu fait
d'avoir reporté
la conclusion est d'avoir de faire
simplement maintenant un petit format en
vidéoconférence fait qu'il n'est pas
possible de conclusion mais concrètement
est ce que l'union européenne ne vais
pas se froisser avec un partenaire
économique de poids elle qui prend quand
même des positions sur des sujets
politiques notamment sur les droits de
l'homme la situation des bruits courent
hong kong également la 5g
comment collaborer avec la chine sans
brader ses principes pour l'union
européenne
justement il ya beaucoup de choses que
changer pour moi dans la vision de la
chine
tous les pays européens et pas seulement
d'ailleurs les pays européens d'avoir
une eau à contexte de conflit commercial
entre les etats-unis et la chine
il y avait ce que vous avez cités comme
un problème sur hong kong sur taïwan sur
la mer de chine du sud
sur le velours qui ont ouvert les yeux
un petit peu et puis il faut bien voir
aussi que c'est dire qu'il est dans une
position un peu compliqué vous allez sur
notre pays parce que ça se passe pas si
bien que ça pour lui là-bas donc les la
chine a perdu des amis
suite aux comics 19 et la chine
d'entrain les prix ont beaucoup couvert
les yeux et s'aperçoit que prendre une
position de force vis à vis de la chine
ça peut être extrêmement rentable donc
ils vont le faire et l'allemagne et
elles sont le pays rien le silo sino
compatibles en particulier parce que les
exportations de voitures chinoises de
voitures allemand machines seront très
importantes
l'allemagne a changé a changé d'avis et
l'allemagne venu
maintenant payer ses critiques sur la
sueur écosse en 5e dire commerciales
entre la chine et les états unis qui est
en cours justement est ce que ces
tensions peuvent être bénéfiques pour
pour l'union européenne avec une
ouverture sur le marché chinois est
peut-être quand même avancé sur ce point
là tout à l'heure même si comme vous
avez dit vous n'attendez pas grand chose
de ce sommet alors qu il est évident que
la chine est dans une position tellement
difficile j'avais les est arrivé parce
que non seulement pulp à la halle du
griffon dur mais maintenant bagdad fait
un bon coup avec peuvent passer du
mistral plus dur vu la ville agit donc
la chine maintenant elle a plus que
plein de grands ensembles face à elle 10
l'union européenne et elle sera planté
faire des concessions qu'elle adore
communautaire certainement départ pour
essayer de sauvegarder ce qui peut
déplacer vers l'est merci jean vincent
brisset d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes chercheur
associé à l'iris institut des relations
internationales et stratégiques et
spécialiste de la chine